mais à la Une on connait donc la tête
d'affiche du prochain chambor live et
c'est donc comme on vous l'expliquer en
titre David getta qui se produira aux
abords du château de chambor le samedi
29 juin 2024 après Sting puis imagine
dragons AZP continue de voir les choses
en grand et en international les places
seront mises en vente le 6 décembre
prochain 30000 personnes sont attendues
le prix de 78 à 133 € Aurélie Renaud
cela fait plus de 2 ans que l'équipe
tourangel d'AZ prod est en contact avec
la production de David Guetta le chambor
live sera l'une des uniques dates de
concert en France du DJ David getta est
français donc c'est aussi une fierté
surtout en 2024 sur l'année des des j où
il y a beaucoup de projecteurs sur sur
la France donc ça est plutôt assez fier
après oui c'est difficile puisque David
Guettard malgré qu'il soit français il
est d'une notoriété mondiale donc c'est
de toute façon difficile de faire venir
des artistes de notoriété mondiale tout
l'enjeu et des discussions qu'on a eu
depuis depuis longtemps c'est qu'il a
besoin d'être rassuré et assuré que il
avait la possibité de délivrer un show
unique au monde en fait dj depuis plus
de 20 ans David ga a collaboré avec les
plus grands si Rihanna Justin Bieber ou
encore Lady Gaga question les tourangejo
connaissent-il vraiment David
[Musique]
getetta
les places seront mises en vente à
partir de mercredi 6 décembre à 10h
elles pourrai partir vite l'année
dernière les billets pour imagine
dragons s'était envolé en 10
minutes